crowds gathered in the center of Tunis
they accused president Kaya Saeed of
corrupting Democratic institutions and
wanting absolute power I came here today
because of the coup and the miserable
conditions the country is in today there
is no water or milk no sugar and no
petrol and we have a president who is
only interested in power
[Music]
the two parties organizing the protests
have long been bitter Rivals now both
are focused on the fight against Saeed
leaders of the national salvation front
coalition and the free Constitution
party
urged tunisians to boycott December's
parliamentary elections
[Applause]
the Tunisian people who fought 50 years
for democracy will not allow this coup
to settle they've seen the extent of
mismanagement incompetence and failure
at both rallies protesters called on
Syed to quit and chanted the people want
the fall of the regime the slogan of the
2011 Revolution which sparked the Arab
Spring people are getting really quite
frustrated but there's two counts
there's ones who are fighting for
democracy and those who are just
fighting for a kind of bread and being
able to live a better life and know what
they're going to put on the dinner table
at night
the government hasn't commented on the
latest protests beside says he's working
to improve the economic conditions he
inherited from his predecessors to that
end the Tunisian government has just
secured a 1.9 billion dollar loan from
the IMF
but these protesters say they won't give
up they don't believe the upcoming vote
will be free or Fair they say Saeed has
too much power and democracy is in
danger
Victoria gate and B Al Jazeera